منتدى العمل ااا المشترك السابع الذي كان
في ايران وايضا ان شاء الله خلال زياده
السيد رئيسي رئيس جمهوريه السيد الرئيس
اترك تركيا سيتم عقد المؤتمر المنتدى
الثامن منه
في نهائيات العام الميلادي
السابق كان السيد الرئيس الجمهوريه
الرئيسي كان سيقوم بزياره تركيا لكن ولي
ايييه
وزياره
اعماله
ولكثره همم
انشغالات اا رجوت من الصديق العزيز السيد
شوشو تاجيل هذه موعد هذه الزياره
وان شاء الله س- نشكل هذا لقاء باستضافه
مسؤولي الدوله
بفضل هذه الزيارات
سنكون قد سرعنا
التطورات التي تم قطعها في لقاءات اليوم
في قطاعات على جانب قطاع الطاقه والاقتصاد
اااه
والبيئه
قمنا
بتشاور واستشارات حول هذا ايضا ونحن
متطابقون ومتفاهلون في الحقيقه حول الكثير
من هذه المسائل واذا كان هناك معوقات تجاه
بعض هذه المسائل اكدنا على اهميه العمل
معا لرفع هذه الامور وايضا على الجانب
الامني التعاون في جانب مكافحه الارهاب
يجب ااااااه
نحن نشهد افضل تعاون وعلى ارفع مستوى
وايضا بخصوص التعاون الاقتصادي
وكما ذكر صديقي العزيز السيد شامبو
العلاقات الاقتصاديه والتجاريه بين
الدولتين نعم هي جيده جدا لكن الطاقه
الاستعابيه للدولتين هي اكبر من ذلك بكثير
وفي هذا الاطار
تم تحديده هدف بين الدولتين وايضا خلال
لقاءنا مع السيد رئيس الجمهوريه هو ااه
السيد رئيس جمهوريه ايضا اكد على هذا ايضا
واا
الارقام التي تم تحديدها هدفا ااه لحجم
تجاره وهمم العلاقات الاقتصاديه بين
الدولتين اكد على اهميه خطوه خطوات لرفع
هذا الرقم الى اكبر
ممكن بعد اجاء من اخر فالسوق الحدوديه بين
الدولتين وتفعلها كان هذا الملف ايضا مما
تناولناه
الاسواق الحدوديه الثلاث
همم نفعلها خلال الايام المقبله وايضا
بخصوص ملف المياه كان لنا استشارات وتشاور
مياه نهر الاستفاده منها من قبل الطرفين
بشكل عادي تم تناوله هذا الملف ايضا البحث
المستفيده من هذه المياه سيتم تذليل السبل
لتحقيق الاستفاده القصوى منها
وايضا خلال همم اجتماع اللجنات في الاسبوع
المقبل اا كما ذكر السيد الصديق العزيز
شاويش سيد شوشو تم عقد هذا اجتماع الاسبوع
السابق في طهران وتم التناول الاموم التي
تعني مواطني الدولتين ايضا تبادل
المحكومين بين الدولتين كان هذا احد اهم
المشاهد المسائل التي تم تناولها
اه اه
هذا ايضا سيكون له دور في لم الشمل
بخصوص المسائل الاقليميه نحن دائما
مع اخواننا الاتراك ونحن على استشاره
وتواصل دائما
واما بخصوص العلاقات بين دمشق
وانقرا وتغير خط العلاقات بين الدولتين
نحن ممتنه جدا لذلك نحن جمهوريه ااه ايران
الاسلاميه نحن ممتنان جدا من
[موسيقى]
وصول العلاقات الى هذا المستوى
نحن اااه ندعم ونؤمن باهميه اي خطوه
ايجابيه في اطار علاقات بين الدولتين
ونؤمن به اهميه هذه الخطوات على المنطقه
وعلى مستقبل علاقات بين المنطقه ونحن
كدوله تراقب هذه المرحله نحن سنقوم بكل ما
بوصعنا بخصوص تطوير العلاقات وايضا بخصوص
ملف الحرب في اوكرانيا قمنا
بالاستشارات والتشاور المتبادل
مواقف ايران تجاه حرب اوكرانيا تم توضيحه
دائما على ارفعي مستوى نحن دائما ضد
الحربي ونقف الى جانب الحلول السلميه همم
بعض الدول الغربيه
حاولت من خلال حرب اوكرانيا فرض عقوبات
وتقيده همم ايران لكننا نرفض هذه المحاوله
دائما وايضا كما ذكر صديقي العزيز همم
قمنا بالتشاور حول ملف افغانستان اليوم
الحكومه المؤقته في افغانستان واا اعاقتها
تعليم النساء هناك نحن همم
نرفض هذا الموقف ونراه مناقضا لي همم دين
اسلامي والمفهوم الاسلام
ونؤكد دائما على اهميه تشكيل حكومه
حكومه وحده حكومه شامله في افغانستان
تنظيم الوضع في افغانستان تشكيل هذه
الحكومه همم التي يتم التوافق عليها مهم
جدا لتحقيق ااه الامني والاستقرار في
المنطقه وبخصوص
القفقاس فاذا جانبي همم
حمايه وحده الاراضي في المنطقه فيجب ان
نحرص على عدم تغيير طبيعه همم
جغرافيه وديموغرافيه المنطقه اكدنا على
هذا همم الامر وايضا بخصوص التجاره
والعلاقات التجاريه بين الدولتين ل همم
يكون
العلاقات دائما ونحقق مستوى كوفاه هي
مطلوب هذا مهم وهمم واكدنا ايضا على اهميه
التعاوني بين الدول الصديق العزيز دائما
ما كان على تواصل معي
نتشاور بخصوص هذا الامر وتجري لقاءات
بيننا ومراسلات ايضا
ونحن جمهوريه ايران اسلاميه نؤمن بامر هو
ان ااا
تصريحات امريكا
المتناقضه اذا تركت امريكا هذه تصريحات
المتناقضه
قامت بالخطوات اللازمه لتحقيق الاتفاق
النووي فان هذا اتفاق وممكن الحدوثه جدا
مره اخرى همم صديقي العزيز السيد شاويش
وفريقه وزاره الخارجيه اشكرهم على حسن
استضافتهم
تسلم تسلم
السيد وزير الخارجيه الايراني اقدم
احترامي لكما بدايه سيكون السيد شوشو
بخصوص الحدود السوريه التركيه والتطورات
في هذه المنطقه اذا وضعنا هذه التطورات
بعين الاعتبار
نظرتكم الى هذا الامر وما هو رايكم حول
هذا الملف لتحقيق توافق مع الجانب السوري
في هذا ملف وشاهدنا ازمات في المنطقه ايضا
كيف نظرتكم الى هذا
للاسف بتاثير من هذه الحرب
التي استمرت 11 عاما
تشكلت في سوريا فرصه لا تفوت بالنسبه لي
الارهاب والارهابيون
اليوم في
الشمال الشرقي للسوريه يقومون بفعالياتهم
وزادوا من فعالياتهم الانقساميه في تلك
المنطقه
في سوريا اليوم
واضح
من بعض الدول وايضا لتقسيم سوريا
وتاسيس الدوله ارهابي في الوقت نفسه
من حدودنا مباشره
هذا بعض الدول في المنطقه همم رغم
موقفنا ضد الاجابه مواقفنا من عوده
المهاجرين همم المهجرين السوريين الى
بلادهم قاموا في تل رفعت وفي شرق الفرات
قاموا
ااا تواجد تنظيم بيكاكا في استمرار
اولئك يهاجموننا
الشعب المظلومه هناك ويسلحون اطفال هناك
وفي العراق
[موسيقى]
اللازمه تجاه الارهاب
روسيا وعدت وامريكا وعدت نحن
توافقنا مع هذين دولتين عام 2017
وتذكرون الهجم الارهابيه على همم
المدرسه على الحدود التركيه و استشهد
استشهدت معلمه واستشهد طالب وبالتالي
فعلينا مكافحه الارهاب معا
اللقاءات التي نقوم بها مع النظام السوري
وكما ذكرت من قبل مسائل همم مكافحه
الارهاب ووحده الاراضي السوريه وضع
اللاجئين وعودتهم الى بلادهم وطبعا
المرحله السياسيه بالطبع
ضمن 2254